manche sie haben gerade schon gehört das
ist einer der höhepunkte wenn bushido
dann heute wirklich aussagen soll wie
brisant könnte das vor allem für arafat
abou chaker sein
naja bushido ist inner circle gewesen
gehört nicht zur familie und ist inner
circle haben alles mitbekommen
jede telefonat gespräche absprachen
einmischung in irgendwelche musik
verträge hat alles mitbekommen und das
kann natürlich jetzt auch der fallstrick
für arafat abou chaker sein genau soll
heute der prozess tag ablaufen
ja um 10 uhr 30 wird im saal 500 das ist
der terroristen seien
und da panzerglas wird bushido anfang
auszusagen
es ist für mehrere tage angedacht dass
er seine aussage von anbeginn an von
aggro berlin aus dem jahre 2003 und den
kontakt zu der apotheker von mir
bekommen hat darüber soll ja anfang aus
zusammen es ist dann sicher dass er
jetzt aussagen wird immer wieder ist es
ja bei prozessen vor allem gegen den
apotheker klaren so dass zeugen in
letzter sekunde dann doch nicht aussagen
sich nicht erinnern
wie wird das jetzt für heute eigentlich
für die aussage von bushido der selber
auch als nebenkläger auftritt
das ist ziemlich sicher haben ja steht
unter zeugenschutz die ganze familie und
er wird auspacken im detail sehr
interessant ist dabei auch der
vorsitzende richter martin roß er ist
als newcomer als senkrechtstarter mit
anfang 40 schon jetzt ein vorsitzender
richter einer großen strafkammer
er war bislang nur ergänzungsrichter
falls eine richter ausfällt eingesetzt
das ist ein erster großer prozess und er
wird bushido jetzt mehrere tage lang
befragen ist es für die nächsten zwei
wochen keine weiteren zeugen geladen so
lange wird man bushido hier in die
mangel nehmen wollen am ende dieses
prozesses was droht dann half alaba und
auch seinen brüdern seine brüder sind
nicht ganz so
angeklagt mit den schweren vorwürfen
aber vorab hat könnte eine
gesamtfreiheitsstrafe schon in betracht
kommen versuchte schwere räuberische
erpressung ist ein verbrechenstatbestand
es wird nicht unter einem jahr bestraft
sollte ja deswegen verurteilt werden
kommt eine ganz empfindliche
freiheitsstrafe in betracht
natürlich wirst du uns dann über die
aussagen von bushido auf dem laufenden
halten aber ganz am ende vielleicht
nochmal die erklärung dazu die beiden
waren meine besten freunde waren
geschäftspartner fast wie familie
was ist also passiert dass sie sich
heute vor gericht so wieder treffen
ja so wie es heißt hat arafat so
2016/2017 immer mehr den hang zu seiner
religion gefunden ist auch in eine
obskure moschee in neukölln gegangen hat
dort freitagsgebete besucht und fing
dann an auch einfluss auf das
familienleben von bushido zu nehmen er
hat sich über seine frau beklagt und
anna-maria und hat auch aufgefordert
dass sie sich züchtiger kleinen soll das
alles führte dann dazu dann eskalierte
dann letztendlich endet 2017 dazu dass
bushido diesen ganzen kontrakt den pakt
mit dem teufel auflösen wollte